hello my name is raymond alvarez and i
am co-founder of i-core biologics
as well as an assistant professor in the
division of infectious diseases at the
icann school of medicine at mount sinai
um and first i'd like to
thank the organizers for inviting me to
speak about
some of the things i've been doing over
the last several years involving
fc gaming receptor signaling during
viral infections
so i think this subject is quite
pertinent in the environment that we're
currently in
so as you all well know at the end of
last year
um there was a uh stars kobe 2 pandemic
outbreak that currently uh has infected
24.2 million people worldwide with 5.8
million people
in the u.s currently the mortality rates
are running at 3.5 percent worldwide and
3.1 percent
in the u.s and so all the urgency of
this pandemic has
sent um scientists racing to develop
vaccines that elicit
neutralizing antibody responses in
parallel
other researchers are focusing on
developing antibody based
therapeutics that can be passively
infused into acutely infected
individuals
so um i think this has put um
a spotlight on antibodies although the
emphasis has mostly been placed on
the neutralizing capacity of antibodies
whereby
the antibody targets of the viral
antigen that interacts with the host
receptor
thereby preventing permissive
or infection into permissive target
cells
however the back half of the antibody
also has
functional properties so the antibody is
a bifunctional
molecule whereby the back half the fc
constant region
mediates non-neutralizing antibody
responses
and the way this occurs is that the
antibody is able to recognize
either viral particles or virus infected
cells
and then the fc portion the constant
region of the antibody then interacts
with
fc receptors on the surface of innate
immune effector cells
this interaction then causes such
effector responses as antibody dependent
cellular cytotoxicity phagocytosis
and cytokine production so
these responses are mediated by
a family of fc receptors and in
particular
the family that recognizes igg
antibodies
are fc gamma receptors and so what
happens
is that once an antibody antigen complex
is detected by these fc receptors they
become cross-linked
and so this family of fc gamma receptors
consists of six activating and
inhibitory receptors
and because of their different
affinities as well as their ability to
both activate and inhibit
um effector responses
they modulate the immune system in
response to
[Music]
pathogens so
two there are two primary uh
pro-inflammatory fc gamma receptors
which is fc gamma 2 and fc gamma 3
and they mediate a lot of antibody
effector functions
and so um these effector functions are
adcc as i mentioned
where uh an effector population detects
um an antibody-oxidized infected cell
and then releases
uh preferred and granzione to kill that
cell
antibody-opsinized cells can also be
detected by
phagocytic cells which uh like
macrophages which end up phagocytosing
and killing
infected cells and also antibody antigen
complexes can be
taken up by dendritic cells the antigen
then
being processed and presented to the
cellular arm of the immune system
so all of this can mediate the
expression of cytokines which further
dictates the environment in which an
immune response is
conducted and so further regulation
of fc receptor interactions are mediated
by
the different subclasses of igg
antibodies
and here you can see igg one through
four
and so depending on what subclass is
targeting the antigen
you'll get subtle regulation of fc
receptor interactions
um adding to this regulation is the
potential glycosylation that occurs in
the fc region of the antibody
and um you can see here the variety of
glycosylation patterns that can occur
which add to the potential complexity
and subtlety
of disease regulation another variable
is cell type and so you can see here
that
fc receptor expression is target cell
dependent
so you have quite a variety of different
types of effector populations that
express different levels of
of fc receptors and their expression can
vary
depending on tissue localization
so all of these factors contribute to fc
regulation of immune responses so
antibody affinities subclass
glycosylation
epitope targeting and avid ability as
well as multivalency
so all of these factors contribute to
how fc receptors orchestrate the immune
response
so you can see how complex and how
subtle
the system is in terms of being able to
regulate immune responses
so um now i'd just like to turn our
attention to
how potentially or how fc receptor
signaling has been shown to be involved
in
viral infections and so in the context
of
influenza we can see here the
hemoglobin envelope protein it consists
of a globular head
as well as a stock region and
researchers have found that
anti-hemagglutinin
antibodies that are directed against the
globular head actually have very
efficient neutralization
but they have very poor fc gamma
receptor activation
this is good for strain specific
responses so we get seasonal flu and it
responds to that particular strain
however recent developments have
identified antibodies that target the
stock region
of um hemagglutinin and what these
antibodies do
is uh they also can mediate um neutral
neutralizing and non-neutralizing
responses however these non-neutralizing
responses can
um recruit effector cells and
mediate more effective immune responses
what's interesting about these
anti-stock antibodies is that they're
broadly reactive
so the regions in the stock are more
conserved amongst more strains
so the basis for a universal influenza
vaccine
is developing around eliciting these
anti-stock broadly reactive antibodies
to then generate a universal influenza
vaccine
so other evidence of the importance of
fc gamma receptor signaling
in viral infections come from the field
of hiv
where the first clinical trial to show
protection from the acquisition of hiv
also came up with the first immune
correlates with protection
and those correlates were not
neutralizing antibodies
nor were they cellular responses
um what protection did correlate with
were high titers of non-neutralizing
antibodies particularly against
the v1 v2 region of the hiv envelope so
the crown region of hiv omf
and these non-neutralizing antibodies
seem to mediate
higher adcc responses against the virus
so further evidence of fc receptor
involvement in the individual control of
hiv comes from
my own work in at mount sinai where we
examined
um a cohort of byremic controllers that
had viral loads below a thousand to
undetectable levels
in comparison to hiv chronically
infected patients
and what we observed was that while
environment controllers and chronically
infected individuals had similar
anti-hiv envelope levels
and also similar levels of
neutralization activity
what we did find was that they had that
hiv controllers had an enhanced capacity
to mediate
fc gamma 2 and fc gamma 3 signaling
so what this is showing is that
while the quantitative aspects of
antibody responses in both these
populations are fairly similar meaning
that the titers are very similar
um the qualitative responses seem to be
different
in that since hiv controllers mediate
higher levels of exchange receptor
signaling
this potentially implies that um they're
mediating
um this is contributing to more
effective immune responses in vivo
so further evidence of the involvement
of fc receptor
involvement in hiv comes from studies
examining broadly neutralizing
antibodies
where in this case the broadly
neutralizing b12
had the uh had its fc region ablated
and then this antibody was passively
infused into macaques
and infected with shiv models of
infection
with a wild type antibody what you see
here is that it maintains both
neutralization
as well as fc receptor function and it
pretty much controls
virus replication in vivo however once
you remove the
fc the ability of this antibody to
interact with fc receptors
you then lose this ability to control
virus replication in vivo
another example of this comes from
the another broadly neutralizing
antibody bnc117
where experiments with this antibody
that also
knock out fc receptor function or
further optimize it to enhance
fc receptor activity
was examined in models of humanized
mouse models of hiv infection
and so here we can see that in
comparison to wild type
the monoclonal antibodies that maintain
neutralizing function but have
their fc of the interaction ability
deleted have higher levels of infection
as compared to wild type
and the converse is true for
antibodies that have enhanced fc
interaction where they have a little bit
less infection as compared to wild type
this is further
corroborated with the viral loads where
the
fc optimized antibody mediates us or
we see significantly lower levels of
viral loads in these animals
so while fc receptor
responses seem to be very uh important
for controlling
virus infections in vivo that's not
always the case in every single type of
virus infection
in fact in dengue infection there are
four serotypes of dengue infection
and what happens is that you get initial
primary infection with one serotype
you then develop an immune response
against this serotype
and then the danger then comes in with
um infection with a secondary uh
serotype of dengue
this reactivates your memory response
but your memory response has been set by
your primary infection
so this leads to an inefficient control
of the secondary serotype infection
this causes elevations in um anti-igg
responses against dengue which
correlates with the severity of disease
and
dengue hemorrhagic fever so um
this caused a initial hypothesis that
maybe the
antibodies themselves were exacerbating
disease
um and studies further showed this um
to be true where in vitro studies have
shown that anti-dengue antibodies
mediate
enhanced entry infection of leukocytes
and this is via
fc receptor mediated uptake further in
vivo studies have shown
that polyclonal serum from severe dengue
and
severely infected dengue individuals or
monoclonal
antibodies mediate pathogenic effects
and further clinical studies have also
shown that
severe dengue is correlated with
enhanced fc gamma 3 signaling in
particular
a particular glycosylation state is
associated with that
moreover uh enhanced polymorphisms that
enhance
fc gamma receptor detection of
antibodies have further been correlated
with disease severity so we can see how
the regulation of sa receptors may be
very important for disease
so we wanted to begin to look at what fc
receptor signaling looked like
in sars kovi ii and so
there have already been uh immune
profiles of mild versus severe patients
and what's been found is that in mild
covid19
what we see is a initial
upregulation of type 1 interferon which
is our body's
way of alerting that there is a viral
infection
occurring and it activates lots of
interferon stimulated genes which act to
counteract virus replication so in
mild disease you have this peak of type
1 interferon
which you have some level of replicating
virus which then
begins to get controlled you have
lower levels of inflammation and this
coincides with
less disease severity
whereas in severe covid19 disease
you have a delay of type 1 interferon
responses
where you have earlier phases of
uncontrolled virus replication
and seven to ten days after the onset of
symptoms
you then get escalating inflammation
and disease severity so what these
inflammation coincides with is what has
been
deemed cytokine storms but really what
this is
is an elevated profile of specific
cytokines
mainly tnf il-6 and il-8
these inflammatory cytokines and this
increased inflammation and disease
severity also coincides
with increasing levels of anti-spike igg
this has led researchers to speculate
that potentially ade
is involved in these responses
so other evidence of potential ade
in coronavirus infections comes from
stars one
and where in vitro studies have shown
that
anti-spike antibodies for against stars
1
mediates higher levels of virus entry
into target cells
this is called antibody dependent
enhanced infection
further evidence comes in vivo where
either through passive infusion of
anti-spike antibodies or vaccine-induced
anti-spike antibodies cause more acute
lung injury and cytokine expression in
macaque models of infection the caveat
to this though
is that in monkey models there is a
resolution of infection
and this resolution of infection or the
decrease in viral titers
coincide with the lung injury
of phenotype and resolving as well
a further caveat to the in vitro data
here is that
while increases a while uh
antibodies increase entry into
macrophages and monocytes the population
thought to
cause the elevated cytokine expression
monocytes and macrophages do not
productively become infected
with sars cov1 and sarsko b2
so to begin to kind of clarify whether
the involvement of fc receptor
signaling in covet 19 we gathered a
cohort of convalescent individuals
these individuals were um antibody
positive or antibody negative
they were 28 antibody positive 28 20
antibody negative
they were sex and age matched fairly
well
importantly the time from which we
there was an onset of symptom in these
patients the time we drew blood
was approximately 43 days that was the
median for the population
and this is very important in that 43
days is optimal
since you don't want to get a too early
of a time point where
igg levels have not peaked yet and you
don't want to get
too late of a time point where igg
levels begin to wane
we've also collected a blood type data
on
all of our donors as well as under any
underlying conditions
in these individuals so the first thing
that we wanted to do was assess their
anti-spike antibody levels and we use
this using a cell-based system
whereby we transfected 293ts with the
sarskovi-2 spike protein
this then expresses the protein on its
surface and allows for
detection by donor-derived igg
this igg was purified igg from these
convalescent donors
we then come in with an anti-human igg
antibody that has a fluorescence marker
on it and we can then detect the level
of
of antibodies via fluorescence uh flow
cytometry
so we can see here that we have very
little background on
a negative sample whereas even with
low samples we get good resolution
and detection this is true also for
samples that have intermediate levels of
anti-spike binding as well as
high levels of anti-spike binding
so in you can see here that the
resolution of the assay
is very good where uh the negative
sera is giving us about a two log
difference between
uh the lowest positive sample that we
see here
and we have about a two log resolution
between the
lowest co b2 positive sample
antibodies positive sample and the
highest
we can further see a breakdown of this
here where you see the spectrum of
anti-spike antibody levels in these
convalescent individuals
importantly in these four individuals
with red arrows
they actually tested negative on
commercial tests um
these tests are normally uh these were
elisa based
tests and they actually said that these
individuals were negative
however um we were able to pick them up
with our assay which
is evidence that our assay is very
sensitive even detecting low levels
and since we have a two log difference
between real negative samples and low
level positive samples we're fairly
confident at these results
also these individuals did also test pcr
positive for stars kobe 2.
so we also collected a symptomology
of these infected individuals and so you
can see here the list of symptoms
attached to a severity score
we asked each of our donors to
self-report
the severity of each of these symptoms
what this allowed us to do is come up
with a composite
a total severity score for each
individual while each individual did not
have every single one of these symptoms
they had a various array of symptoms and
we could add those scores up to a total
composite score
when we did that and compare that to the
anti-spike levels we saw that the cohort
pretty much divided into mild versus
moderate
in scores that were above 45 and
below 45. so we then use this to look at
anti-spike levels and saw that the
anti-spike levels were significantly
higher
in individuals that had severity scores
of above 45.
so next we wanted to assess the level of
fc gamma receptor signaling in these
convalescent individuals
and we again expressed sars cov2 and
incubated with uh donor derived igg
except this time we co-cultured these
cells with reporter cell lines that
expressed fc receptor cells on their
surface
upon igg detection these cells
cross-link fc receptor
causing a signaling to occur and
luciferase production
we then can detect luciferase production
as a surrogate marker for level of fc
activation
so in doing this we see that there is
enhanced
fc gamma 2 and fc gamma 3
in convalescent donors with severity
scores above 45.
further when we looked at the level of
fc gamma uh signaling in contrast to the
level of
kobi2 antibody binding we found a
significant correlation
however with fc gamma 3 this correlation
was very striking it seemed
almost like a completely linear
correlation where the level
of anti-spike antibody um
very well correlated with the level of
fc gamma receptor signaling
so what this implies at least with this
small
cohort of convalescent individuals is
that fc gamma receptor
signaling goes up in proportion with the
level of anti-spike
antibodies um so
this was very nice in a a set of
convalescent individuals however
we wanted to see how this was reflected
in the hospitalized population
and through a collaboration with sarad
mahandra of mount sinai
we were able to get a handful of
hospitalized individuals
we also looked at their level of
anti-spike binding and what you can see
here
is the level of anti-spike binding in
low versus
high individuals and we also see here
what it looks like in a severe igg
individual and you can see how there's a
marked elevation in the level of
anti-spike antibody binding
when we graph our convalescent cohort
in comparison to hospitalized
individuals we see that there's a very
significant elevation in anti-spike
antibodies in hospitalized
severe and hospitalized individuals and
this is almost a log
um a log full
a log higher as compared to the mean of
our convalescent cohort
when we further divide the level of
anti-spike
antibody levels in those with severity
scores below 45
above 45 and compared to the severe and
hospitalized individuals you see this
clear stair step
in the level of anti-spike antibody
so we next having seen this elevation
and anti-spike
even beyond our cohor our convalescent
cohort levels we wanted to see what the
level of fce gamma receptor activation
was in these patients
and what we observed was with fc gamma 2
we did see a trend towards significantly
higher fc gamma 2
and we did see significantly higher fc
gamma 3 activation
so it does look as if both anti-spike
and fc gamma receptor activation
correlates with severity of covid19
so what we have here is we're left with
a question
of are there likely ade effects in
covid19
and what we've observed is an increase
in the titers of anti-spike antibodies
however we've seen an increase in afghan
receptor signaling
but it's nowhere near the full
difference that we observed
in the level of anti-spike antibody
binding so
we think that while these in vitro
results are very interesting
in vivo results are in vivo studies are
warranted
with the important caveat that with hiv
and ebola
there are in vitro correlates that have
not panned out
in vivo with ade effects so
in summary fc gamma receptor activation
in uh viral infections we've seen that
efficient fc gamma receptor activation
correlates with the ig mediated control
and clearance
of infections in vivo however with some
pathogens such as dengue
enhanced iggfc interactions may actually
exacerbate disease
with covid19 we've seen that
anti-spike antibody levels correlate
with disease severity scores
in convalescent individuals and also
high levels of fc gamma 3 and fc gamma 2
activation correlate with higher
anti-spike levels in both convalescent
and severe hospitalized individuals
so lastly i'd just like to take a moment
to acknowledge
some of the people doing this fantastic
work that we've been doing
um at i-core biologics so the cohort
samples were gathered and consented
through our company i-core biologics and
this project was spearheaded
by our chief scientific officer jose
luis garrido
with help from our our great staff of
felipe nicole sarah and
sheila i'd also like to thank our
collaborators surab mahandra at mount
sinai for
the hospitalized sample as well as our
collaborator mary
marianas baria and mario calgo
who are currently collecting more
samples for us to process and i'd like
to give a special thanks to all of our
blood donors
thank you